well a group of actors in Los Angeles
deeply informed by spending over an hour
on Twitter have banded together to
produce videos supporting Christine Ford
and demanding a halt to Brett kapnos
confirmation the Supreme Court what we
know how difficult it is to stand up to
powerful people he should not be
confirmed he should not be confirmed he
should not be confirmed I don't know any
of those people you probably don't
either
Dean Cain does though he's an actor and
producer he's from Los Angeles his dad
was in the business he joins us tonight
what do you make of that oh wow look
sexual assault I feel for any victim for
assault no question male or female but
that is just completely political
where's the video for Karen Monahan you
know keith Ellison is accused where's
where's the full-length movie for the
Bill Clinton accusers it just doesn't
exist it's completely political and and
that's kind of tragic because sexual
assault is a very serious very serious
thing and it kind of cheapens it because
they're doing this specifically for
political it's such a good point I mean
these are not standards they apply
equally so Kermit Gosnell was an
abortion doctor in Philadelphia who
abused will killed a bunch of valuables
children right but also be used all
these women people tried to make a movie
about it in Los Angeles and not everyone
was on board you actually did make
reading about it no that's a reaction
well first of all we had to raise the
money on IndieGoGo cuz nobody would pay
for it we did that and we made the film
and I think it's a very good film it
comes out October 12th and nobody would
put it out there nobody would distribute
it so we finally found distribution so
two years ago we finished the film now
we can tell the story and it's it's
because it deals with abortion we
couldn't even buy ad time on NPR because
we called him an abortion doctor we had
to call him just a doctor so if nobody
watched it'd was commit abortion I mean
he wasn't he wasn't doing appendectomies
no he was also pushing drugs and got
busted on a narcotics charge that's how
it started but this guy are you worried
about I mean that's one subject that
you're kind of not allowed to deviate
from the prevailing view are you
concerned now for yourself not at all I
you know I'm up a certain age now where
I'm not that concerned but I'm gonna
tell stories that I want to tell I'm not
worried about if it has a repercussion
on my
on my job or my hiring it should never
do that to tell stories and we're
telling a true story this happened I
play a real-life detective James Wood
and this happened and and the way we
tell the story we don't take a side on
it
I actually impro Joyce which shocks
people to a degree up until viability of
a child like then by then I can't I hope
I would never I would never abort my own
child I would never want that but I'm
not gonna tell somebody what they can do
with their body and that surprised a lot
of people that I would make this film
but I think the film the film is hugely
important and should get out there and
people should make up their own minds
man I I hope that all of our viewers
watch this movie I'm gonna watch the
movie and I think I think you're a brave
man for doing it thank you tough either
way because that is everybody who spent
a lot of time living in liberal America
where I live and where you live you know
that's the one subject you can't you
can't have your own views on
no absolutely not well good for you Dean
Cain it is great to see you thanks
doctor